[Music]
Justin Bieber said that he hoped and
Frank would have been a belieber yeah
that's right I didn't make that up I
couldn't have made that out and you
think Bieber would learn his lesson
after saying he said that people got
shocked you'd think he'd learned his
lesson apparently he hasn't look at this
report on today's Good Morning America
many are in disbelief over Justin
Bieber's latest move leaving what some
are calling a tasteless comment at the
end Frank Museum in Amsterdam according
to museum officials he spent an hour
touring the museum on Friday then upon
leaving wrote this in the guestbook
truly inspiring to be able to come here
and was a great girl hopefully she would
have been a believer but that wasn't all
Justin then took to Twitter to weigh in
on other inspiring figures from history
first tweeting thinking a lot about Joan
of Arc lately a 19 year old hero who was
burned at the stake
I'm 19 2 and my career is also on fire
next Justin sweetest shoutout to Jesus
if it wasn't for his birth the world
would never know my 2011 Xmas CD under
the mistletoe still available on iTunes
hashtag Jesus hashtag me and finally
martin luther king jr. had a dream and
made history my new fragrance has also
made history as the top-selling perfume
during Macy's third fiscal quarter
hashtag profits hashtag racism
[Applause]
[Music]